again
as chair of the house of ways and means
committee i find that due to the state
of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session on revenues
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaries
into this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order and confirming
that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar and
general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs at lake.state.nht
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
jennifer four committee researcher
and please note that all votes that are
taken
during this meeting should be done by
roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also
state whether there's anyone in the room
with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law uh
representative bernstein could take all
the roles
thank you mr chairman good morning to
you and good morning to everyone it's
uh may the fourth
fifth fifth sorry thank you may the
fifth
and it's currently 10 04 a.m we'll begin
roll call with representative patrick
abrami
yes i'm here in my home in stratham and
my wife is in the house
representative mary griffin
representative jordan owenry
home hudson wife is in the house
representative ober hudson
wife is meeting with the governor at the
moment six cats are still here
when do the cats get to meet with the
governor russ
probably never representative doucette
good morning mr clerk home alone my home
office in salem
good morning your clerk is alan burstein
i'm in my home in nottingham new
hampshire in my health office by myself
representative robert elliott i'm in my
daughter's
home in salem new hampshire there's no
one else in the house but me and the cat
she's going to charge your rent real
soon bob yeah
representative to niggian yes hello i am
in my home office in salem and my wife
is in the house
representative nunes good morning mr
clerk happy cinco de mayo
i am home alone in pelham representative
baxter
thank you mr clerk good morning to you
my camera is still not
working and i'm here with my father as
well
good morning and hello dad
representative spillsbury
good morning i'm home alone in
charlestown
morning i'm home in northwood wife and
grandkids
uh upstairs representative
i'm alone in lebanon on i'm going to
have to leave
about 5 minutes to 11 for a meeting
representative ames i'm here in jeffrey
in my home office alone
representative southworth here in dover
hello
representative malloy here alone in
greenland
representative thomas schamberg thank
you representative bernstein
i'm here in wilmette with my cinco de
mayo hat on and i'm home alone
we want pictures representative tucker
representative gomarlo aaron swansey
alone
representative laughman representative
gorg
good morning i am present and alone good
morning representative hacken phillips
oh there you are good morning everybody
i'm
coming to you live from my concord
office alone
good representative murphy good morning
i am home alone
uh in hanover chairman major
good morning i'm in my home uh my wife
is also here
very good mr chair there are 21 members
present
three are absent
thank you representative bernstein
this morning
we have a few issues to discuss
one is uh
teresa rosenberg a cpa is going to talk
about the ppp loans relative to the
taxes that customers that have paid the
taxes
already and so we can get a feel on
how much of the 274 million dollars that
we have
beyond the plan and business taxes this
is associated with the ppp
loan and if senate bill 3
passes as is how much of that
would have to be refunded then we're
also going to
hear from crochet
about the four items
that subtract from our revenue stream
such as
money going to dhhs or the l chip
or the affordable uh housing
primary history now that evolved
and hopefully we won't see many more of
those hopefully some of these will
disappear
and then we want to talk with the dra
on the latest update on
the senate bill 3 issues
finally representative romney wants to
talk about
house bill 565.
and i think a senate bill
uh and on and on this book
on this bill that senate has which
also associated with one section
is almost word for word house house bill
565.
so we'll start off as teresa rosenberg
here
yes i've promoted her to panelist
teresa thank you for being here this
morning
thank you very much can you hear me yes
thank you very much uh representative
major and members of the committee
uh on your i think
your screen you may see carl heathfield
and kevin kennedy these are cpas that
i have brought that would love to talk
to you about
what they and there have done for their
clients
with the ppp um tax
and carl is from one of the largest cpa
firms
in the state and kevin has a smaller in
smaller firms so i thought it was good
to have both
so you can see the treatment they have
they both their their companies have
applied
also robin abbott who is the executive
director of the cpa
society took a straw poll
over the weekend and carl and kevin can
give you results of that as well
so if you could um allow
carl and kevin in that would be great
because they are the ones who prepare
the returns
um i don't i wish i were that clever but
i'm not
that was what i was going to ask you so
janine would you like kyle and kevin and
just did it thank you
thank you
go ahead theresa
i think or carl if carol and kevin are
there they can start
hello everybody good morning
um go ahead and start
yeah kevin do you want to start or
would you like me to no go ahead okay
um hi good morning everybody um my name
is carl hefield and i
as theresa just mentioned i'm with um
uh baker newman noyes uh we're
i'm based out of the manchester office
um
and i also am uh i'm representing the
cpa society today as as
uh the co-chair of the their tax
committee along with kevin
kennedy um i i guess
maybe if you we could start by just um
getting the question on the table that
you would like us to address just so we
make sure we've
we're answering the questions that you
want to hear hear about
um maybe that's the best way to start
the real question is is our
business taxes are about 275 million
dollars ahead of plan this year
and since we hadn't passed senate bill
three
and the taxes in new hampshire were due
april 15th then those businesses that
received the ppp loans and this is about
25 000 of my best
would have to report this as income
and pay the taxes on it now
we would like to get a feeling is
did they do that and
and if we do pass senate bill 3
as is then we would see a lot
of requests for refunds
later on in the year when they
file their extension or whatever so
that's our issue
is to try to identify this
vocal money that we have that we had
anticipate
how much of that might be associated
with the ppp loans that
uh if we pass senate bill three
we're going to have to pay back
because if we don't do that people will
see
we have this money sitting here and the
natural thing for politicians today is
we've got money let's spend it
and we need to warn them uh
what the potential here is if we go one
way or the other
so that's the question so
i can uh provide a couple of comments on
that and
uh the first is i i don't see that we'd
be able to quantify
that in any means just because there's
simply not enough data
but i think relative to some of your
considerations as to what this amount
might be
[Music]
the the ppp loans
are taxable in new hampshire based on
the current law
when the loans are forgiven and
a vast majority of people who received
ppp loans
were not forgiven as of 12 31
20 for various reasons um
and because of that it's unclear based
on the
funds that were received how what
percentage of that is actually because
people were anticipating the taxation of
the ppp funds
or something else so
if indeed it does become non-taxable
the the overpayment amounts associated
with that
are probably not clear simply because
people only would have paid and included
that amount to the extent that they were
forgiven
and so so that's one issue
the other issue is is that payments
received i believe included
extensions and a lot of firms
because they were unclear as to the
status of sb3
prepared extensions a large number of
extensions for their business clients
and on the premise that the amount would
be taxable
they included with their extension
payment a payment to cover
the amount that's taxable if it turns
out not to be taxable then
any overpayment associated with the 2020
return that was included in the
extension payment
would likely be carried forward to
subsequent payments or potentially
refunded
um so to the to the big question
quantifying it is not easy but
i think there are a lot of
considerations relative to
how the ppp funds actually are related
to
that that excessive excess amount of
revenue
and you started off by saying that
there's a lot of
ppp loans that haven't been forgiven is
that because
uh the small business association just
hasn't caught up
with the paperwork and that these would
be forgiven because if you took out a
ppp
loan you take it out because
meeting certain requirements that you're
going to use at least 60
on wages and
and the rest of it to support uh
maintaining
your uh employees
i think the reason that there's a lot
that haven't been forgiven is twofold
one is
you may recall that the time period to
use the ppp funds were extended
and because of that people didn't
actually
utilize their funds or were in a
position to apply for forgiveness by the
end of the year because
certain conditions of the ppp fund
allowed you to
rectify say shortages and full-time
equivalent
employee counts through the end of the
year
actually i think a larger part of the
reason forgiveness was not actually
applied for so it's not
the sba that's necessarily behind its
people
hadn't actually applied for forgiveness
with their banks
partly because when the second round of
ppp funds became available
banks refocused their systems
to process the second draw payments and
many of them
shut down the ppp application
forgiveness
process so people clients businesses
couldn't actually apply for forgiveness
because those portals at the banks
weren't available to them
so they could apply for ppp loans
uh knowing that they weren't going to
use them
to retain employees no they they applied
for the loans and used the funds
appropriately
but the loan it's it the amount they
received is a loan
by new hampshire regulations it's a loan
until it's actually forgiven
and so based on the current law the ppp
funds are not considered taxable
until the loan is actually forgiven so
until the sba
agrees to forgive the debt it's a loan
on the books and not included in
state taxable income but they but they
knew
that they were applying that they use
these ppp
loans for maintaining their
their employees all right so they did
the right thing
so they know eventually uh
they would be eligible to have their
loans forgiven
in theory most most most businesses i i
believe use the funds appropriately and
expect to be forgiven if they haven't
been already
so if that's the case then
eventually if sb3 passes
and they had filed their returns paying
the tax
because they used current law they're
going to get that money back
for the amounts for the amounts that
were forgiven in 2020 for the 2020
return
if the loan is forgiven in 2021
um and sp3 does not pass then that
income would be included on their 2021
return of course i'm referring to a
calendar year return
right um
can i just add maybe just to help
clarify i
so i think what what we're saying and
what we've seen in our practice
is that um some ppp
recipients um had their loans forgiven
in 2020
those taxpayers
filed most of them at least from what we
can
you know from what we've seen in our
practice we'd have filed extensions
because they weren't sure
what the final law was going to be on
ppp loans so they filed extensions
paid paid their extension payments as if
the ppp
loans were taxable and
if if sp3 passes as it is they
those uh those taxpayers will have an
overpayment that will either get
refunded
or applied to future periods
the taxpayers that did not
apply for forgiveness in 2020 and are
applying for forgiveness
in 2021 will face the same
issue um next year so
you know if it's if it's still unclear
um
they you know it'll be a next year issue
but the the impact for those
for those taxpayers who are who will
apply for forgiveness in 2021
won't be felt until um
you know around this time or the summer
of
next um you know next year so 2022
so you know it i don't know what perc i
couldn't really tell you what percentage
of
taxpayers have applied for forgiveness
in 2020 versus the percentage that
applied for forgiveness or will apply
in 2021 um
you know but it's but it's you know
that it's really those it falls into
those two
buckets okay before we open it up
questions since
we do have a
a cert an amount of 270
about 275 million dollars above what's
anticipated
for business taxes
forget about the ppp loans
has the businesses that
remitted their taxes for tax year
have done that well to produce the
difference
a good part of this 275 million dollars
has business has been that but you're
the accountants
you see this because we have to
determine is it just strictly due to
increase in business or
and how much of that is due to ppp loans
um they have to come back
yeah i mean my only response can be
somewhat
anecdotal but there certainly are
businesses that did well um
in spite of kovid um
and so you know some of i would expect
that some of those
um revenues are you know
because businesses generated profits or
you know paid um wages that generated
bet um and then
you know other many other businesses you
know were were negatively impacted
um by the situation and um
so it you know it's really hard to put a
number on that and and
and tell you what percent you know give
you percentages but
there there's certainly some um
you know some population of businesses
that had you know had strong
results in 2021 and and
um those those business taxes whether
they're bet taxes or bp
bpt taxes you know reflect those
results
okay thank you uh representative brownie
has a question
i kind of did but a lot of it's been
answered i think but
um first what percentage of the uh
would you would you guess of the filers
are calendar year filers
um is that is it a majority of the
filers
yes yes most uh most businesses
are or the vast majority are calendar
year filers
um you know there certainly are fiscal
um but the you know
typically though i mean for for
for-profit businesses
um calendar year is the most prevalent
tax year
yeah and i don't know percentage-wise
but it's well over 50 percent
okay and then with the second and the
second wave
of follow-up mr chair um
that was just approved in the end of
december there's
the second phase of this that it ends in
may 31st
uh so what kind of guidance is going out
to
those again that wouldn't affect that
would
obviously affect uh filings for next
year
is that safe to say yes
but in terms of what it uh but these
businesses are doing quarterlies
correct so how how would uh how would
that affect the quarterly payments
yeah um again it's it's sort of all over
uh all over the board depending on the
specific uh client situation or taxpayer
situation
most businesses um would base their
estimates on safe harbor or many of them
would base them on safe harbor so they
would really be basing their quarterly
estimates on their
2021 taxes or what they
what they presume their 2021 taxes to be
um you know
but not all taxpayers would be doing
that some would
project them based on what they expect
their 2022
results to be and um
you know that it would it would seem
that
if the current law is to include
um ppp forgiveness in
the new hampshire tax base uh that they
would be making that
assumption accordingly um and then
then obviously if sb3 passes and
those funds are not taxable they they
would be overpaid
and that would result in some future
refunds
or application of those overpayments to
um to future tax periods
and if i can add a little more
complexity
the a lot of taxpayers actually pay
business enterprise tax
and they receive a credit against their
business profits tax and
the ppp funds if they are taxable
apply to the business profits tax which
increase business profits tax
and if they have enough bet credit
reduces the bet credit or credit carry
forward so
again to add some complexity to it folks
may be simply
understanding what their bet
responsibility is based on their wages
and paying quarterlies based on that
and understanding that even if the bpp
the ppp funds are taxable for business
profits tax
the result is really to eat into the bet
credit that they've got
not necessarily to increase their
overall taxes
okay that that's that's useful thank you
representative thank you
i think i just wanted to clear something
up before my
real question on mr he
he failed on said
that they would be basing what they
will pay in quarterly estimates
this year on the 21 taxes did you mean
20 taxes
um yes i'm sorry 2020 yes they would be
basing them on their 2020
taxes uh for estimates that they're
paying in 2021 yes sorry about that
thanks um we get confused about these
things all the time
on the other uh you
do and do either of you represent um
water's edge on
corporations the huge majority of our
money comes from
just about 100 companies which are
mostly water's edge
and
consolid do consolidated returns
and i'm wondering whether the cpa
society on has
members that are active in that area
or whether they're specialized firms
that are frequently somewhere else
um well i i guess i can
answer and then kevin you can um
you know supplement my answer if if what
i say doesn't apply to your practice but
um for you know for our practice
um even though we are a large firm we're
probably not working with
those types of companies that you've
described
although we may have a few
most of those are very large companies
that would be
represented by much larger national
firms than ours
so i so i don't know we we have we do
have many clients who file
combined new hampshire returns um
but um the amount that
you know of the top 100 taxpayers
um that you're referring to i don't know
if we represent any of those
um you know or you know very few of them
certainly um
sure and i'll add on we we also file
unitary returns for our clients but
because of the size of my firm water's
edges is
not a common issue
thank you very much uh representative
ames
thank you thank you to both
uh of you for joining us to all three of
you i should say
thank you so much um and so we're
we're uh puzzling through this situation
trying to understand
the impact of a of the proposed
senate bill 3 change
and the impact
sort of has two aspects to it one is
on the state's revenues and that's
really what we've been talking about
and the other is on
[Music]
individual businesses and we haven't
talked so much about that
but on the revenue side
the revenue report that we just received
from
dra for this month just ended
april had a huge
increase way beyond historical levels
for april
way out of the norm and if you look at
the sub
categories that dra provides to us
the subcategory for extensions
is the one that really has the huge
increase and there's some sort of more
moderate increase in the estimates
so it's both looking both are looking
forward
um well the age of the extensions is
really looking back
and making some some guesstimates
so my question to you is
and this may you may not be able to
answer this but
could such a huge jump in revenues be
explained mostly or a major part
by what we're talking about here
the change
well the current bbt
[Music]
rule that may be changed by sb3
so the filings now would be on the
assumption
that the rule would not be changed
or uh or end um
might it be that this huge jump reflects
the success of the very big businesses
in this time of covid and the high
profits that have
uh come to these big businesses and as i
say i may be asking too much of you but
uh if you could uh offer your
wisdom on that question i'm sure we
would all
be interested to hear it
okay um you know i think all i
can um
you know the what i can offer is that i
i would say that there were many many
more extensions filed
um for this past year than
historical at least that again that's
what i've seen in our practice and i
just in speaking with other cpas i
it's pretty consistent and not all of
those extensions
are because of ppp loans um
you know not all of those extensions are
for taxpayers that had ppp loans
forgiven in 2020
but there's just a lot more extensions
because
while ppp is one reason that
companies extended um
they may have extended for a bunch of
other reasons i mean there were a lot of
changes over the last year
with the the cares act and with the
follow-up legislation
both for individuals and businesses
that have taken more time for
cpas and clients to sort out so
i think a lot of those you're seeing a
lot more extensions in general
some of those extensions um are related
to the ppp
um uncertainty um
but many of those extensions are just
because of
all the other complexities and um
you know and extra time that's been
that's needed
to prepare um complete returns
so um i guess that's a long way to say i
think a lot of what you're seeing
in the data with respect to the
extensions
is it's not all ppp related it's
there's some of that but um a lot of it
is just
um taxpayers that extended um
for a variety of reasons and um
[Music]
you know i don't i don't know if the if
it's got
if the if the revenue numbers you're
seeing
are because of large companies doing
well
or better than expected
um i again i think it just it really
depends
on a case-by-case basis some did well
and some
did not do so well
i'm afraid i don't have much to add to
uh mr field's comments
um i agree extensions occurred for for a
number of reasons
it's unclear the percentage of
extensions that were filed by large
corporations and if those large
corporations who presumably received
larger ppp funds
had filed for forgiveness so the
amount of businesses the number of
businesses that applied for forgiveness
in 2020
and included that on their extension or
their return
is certainly high but it's unclear in
terms of the dollar amounts
how that spread and if the larger firms
had the resources and the ability to
apply for forgiveness in 2020 and
received them
sooner than uh the vast number of small
businesses who
who didn't apply so again it's just more
more information to to
put in more complexity to the decision
as to what will be the ultimate effect
yeah i i i guess i would also just add
that very large businesses
um you know were not qualified for ppp
loans in the first piece
um you know and again it depends on
their industry and
and uh and there there are exceptions to
that but the
in general the very largest businesses
um
didn't qualify for ppp most very large
businesses
always extend their returns just because
the returns are so complicated they need
all the extra time uh to prepare them
right okay uh a follow-up question
follow up yeah uh thank you
um so switching perspectives to the
business um the uh
federal rule uh it wasn't so clear when
we started out after the
first covet bill was passed by congress
but it became clear
in december the federal that the federal
rule
is that the loan the forgiven loan
proceeds are not um
are not revenue under the uh are not
taxable revenue
and um that deductions may be taken
so it's both both of those elements
and we're contemplating going to the
federal
rule here there's an argument that
that's double dipping so to speak
you the loan
proceeds are excluded
from the tax pitcher and
expenses paid for with those loans
nonetheless
are deducted from other income
and my question to you is
if you can help us
understand the fairness
of doing it the federal way or doing it
to the current stateway which we're
struggling with that question too
and the there is a proposal we have a
pending amendment
before the committee to disallow
disallow to accept the federal
exclusion of the uh forgiven loan
proceeds
but to disallow the deduction of the
expenses that were paid for
by the
forgiven loan and if you could comment
on
how why why is it fair
to our businesses to
[Music]
not allow the deduction
is that unfair i'm not sure i phrased
that exactly right but
maybe you could take a shot at it
so i i guess i'll have i guess my
response to that would be
um you know the society is is neutral on
the bill
um and in terms of fairness i think
that's a
philosophical or political question and
not really one that uh
that we're looking to take a position on
thank you
yeah okay i agree i i i would
um just add that if you
if um if the bill
is amended to exclude um
or to disallow deductions
that's really more confusing for that's
going to be more confusing for
taxpayers than just not passing the bill
all together
in my opinion um i mean either way what
what you know it's just a way to
um to make the
ppp loan proceeds taxable you know
whether you included his income or
disallowed the deductions
it's the same it's the same result the
the
forgiven amount becomes a taxable
cost to the business and i think
the disallowance of the expenses is a
more confusing
um avenue to do that
because um it's much less clear what the
timing
should be of that um
[Music]
recognition of the disallowed should it
go back to the 2020
year when the expenses were um
paid for or does that disallowance
happen
in the year that the um loan is forgiven
you know we'd need more guidance i think
to
for things to be clear so again we
you know we're neutral on the bill um
and
so i don't think i want to get into the
fairness question but i think
it's always important to try to um
at least keep things as clear and simple
as possible
no matter what the you know what the
ultimate result ends up being
well thank you for that that's very
helpful okay before i go to the next
question
um
and kevin do you represent the society
and did you take a vote that you'd be
neutral on this bill
or is that your own ferns
we we don't didn't take a a vote as a
society we
as a society we've um it's our policy
not to advocate one way or the other
for you know for a tax
increases or tax decreases we're
you know what we're trying to do and
what our mission is is to
um help explain how
um different changes in tax law
[Music]
you know impact uh taxpayers
and also you know if we do advocate for
anything as i just said we advocate for
clarity um and
to as much as possible simplicity to
um so that it's easy for taxpayers to
comply
and it's clear as to what the rules are
but
um you know we're not we don't as a
matter of policy and
i mean this has been voted on in general
not
specific to every time we talk about
something but
um you know we we don't advocate for
increases in taxes decreases in taxes
um or you know new taxes
you know we're we're not going to
advocate one way or the other for that
it's
it's just the reporting and compliance
that we advocate for
um you know being as clear as possible
for our clients what you said is
it's much clearer to your clients
and yourselves if uh senator
bill three did not pass
because their client would get the ppp
loans
and then they could and if they use it
for what
they apply for they're not going to pay
any taxes because
it's all deducted
is that correct
yeah i i think the you know the
amendment
that's been proposed to adds confusion
to the timing of when those expenses
don't get deducted and
i mean right now so um
if if you're gonna amend sp3
um for that it would be simpler just to
not pass it at all
and allow the current law um
that's in place that the dra has already
issued guidance on
um to stand because we at this point we
understand
the you know we understand how that
is gonna and we're at a point where
uh it could be the particle when
it's maybe trying to say
you gotta forget it and then if
that's the case in order to be balanced
we'd have to say for those that believe
it this way
is that then you can't deduct the
expenses
if they go to the way of the political
winds
but anyway we'll go to the next question
miss
ribson a major yes i have to leave in 10
minutes could i ask a question that i
think is clarifying before i go
i still can represent elementary thank
you very much
on i don't
thinking about the water's edge
on for on mr
hayfield on do you have any idea
on whether the subsidiaries
of the larger businesses on
were able to qualify for
ppp loans on their own
i've seen some indication of that
looking through who got a ppp loan in
lebanon but
i'm not sure how whether that they were
very small
people those and they probably didn't
get good advice
do you have any idea what the advice
would be on that
uh well i do think i is your if your
question is do
um with subsidiaries of those larger
water's edge groups qualify for ppp
and did some of them receive them i i
think the answer is
yes in certain circumstances i think
there was
um you know the general rule
that businesses over i think 300
employees
could not apply or qualify for ppp there
were exceptions to that and i think
some of those exceptions depended on the
industry so
i believe restaurants and and some
hospitality businesses
could qualify based on their
subsidiaries
you know situation and not not not have
to
sort of look at the larger group
um that they belong to
does does that answer your question so i
so yes i believe
some probably did qualify but and some
didn't
um yeah
okay represents spellsbury
uh yes i think it's been very very
interesting
commentary so far and
i by the way do not in any way disagree
with the notion that just
failing to pass sb3 it might be a
simpler and more direct route
my concern is that if there is a
political will to see sb3
go forward that the amendment may be
necessary and
did i hear you correctly to agree
in your comment uh i believe to
representative ames representative major
that it is essentially true
that all uh ppp loans
must be offset by qualified deductions
in order to be forgiven
yes um so if in order to qualify for
forgiveness
um they have to have used the loan
proceeds for
the various types of expenses that were
allowed under the program
most of those being wages but there were
some other expenses that were also
qualified and so then do you agree
that the the um necessary consequence of
that is that that portion
of their um revenue
attributable to the ppp alone uh
cannot on that be subject to ppt tax
i'm sorry i i i guess i'm kevin i don't
know if you had a
no i'm not sure i understand the
question but to the extent of ppp i'm
glad to rephrase it
all right well if i can offer a response
which may be the answer that
ppp funds a big piece of that were to be
used for wages and in some cases
it was all used for wages so to the
extent that wages were paid with ppp
funds
those wages will be included in the bet
calculation now if
the the issue is that
the sb3 is passed without an amendment
and that it follows essentially the irs
guidelines
the income would not be taxable but the
deductions for payroll would still be
allowed
those deductions for payroll would still
be included in the bet
calculation for the new hampshire return
does that answer your question
different perhaps that helpful i i i
think you're confirming that there is a
b
e t uh impact on uh
from from payroll um but
uh i guess i'm just asking you to
confirm
that there that that to the extent that
uh
ppp loans are forgiven as a result of uh
having been used for qualified expenses
that particular revenue is not
going to generate any tax under rppt
i mean if an sb3 is passed you mean
i mean even if sp3 is not passed
i mean if that's if if if new hampshire
law stays the way it
is and forgiving ppp
is therefore included in taxable income
it will be
entirely offset by the expenses
for which it was used the the expenses
for which it was used will be included
as deductions on the return
yes okay
so there's no net tax effect uh
if i may uh chairman major i had another
question
uh so you know in our search
for uh for evidence and data we of
course
have to rely heavily on anecdote
the problem with anecdote is it's spotty
uh you don't know how well
reinforced it is but i'm thinking of
several
business donors who i know well here in
town
uh with whom i've had conversation on
this topic uh
consistently since march 2020
and i just wonder if i can just describe
those two situations very
briefly whether you find them to be
representative
or aberrations in one case
i'm talking about the owner of a moving
company
and the other case i'm talking about the
owner of a glass company
uh both of them of course were filled
with fear
when the government imposed
limitations came about and uh things
temporarily took a nosedive for their
businesses
in in march and april uh but by may
particularly june july things started to
look differently
and uh they both would have predicted
severe impacts but as it turns out they
both did extraordinarily well
in 2020 in the case of the glass company
they weren't in
installing showers so much but they were
busy all over the place installing
plexiglass dividers in schools and
elsewhere
and in the case of the moving company
virtually nobody moved for a couple of
months and then they saw a surge like
they'd never seen before
and broke all their records in the
second half of the year
so i just i think if we were
sitting here uh 12 to 14 months ago
using our crystal ball we would have
drawn very different conclusions about
who would be winners and who would be
losers
there would have been a temptation to
assume there were no winners
and as things turned out i think maybe
an awful lot of surprises have occurred
in your practice and just
gazing across your clientele um do you
see many similar situations or do you
think that
these were aberrations
um i i have seen some of
those situations um
and then i i've also seen um some
many uh clients who who
did um struggle and were negatively
impacted for the entire year
um you know for and it really just
depends on the business
who their customers were and how their
customers were
impacted and sort of how that trickled
down to them but yeah i've
i i have seen stories like you've
described and i've seen
um many stories of
uh sort of the opposite impact as well
it's you know pretty diverse in terms of
what we've seen
i would agree with carl it's pretty
diverse
so basically the conclusion is there's
no pattern
nothing i can point to
thank you very much okay
representative murphy thank you mr
chairman and uh thanks to our guests for
joining us and i
actually was asking the question that
representative spillsbury just brought
up
in my mind given that the cares act and
the ppp
funds were meant to help employees
stay afloat and employees get paid
pay for health benefits pay for
retirement benefits and wages
and given that you both have said that
your
clientele is not the water's edge of the
large corporations
it probably is even more appropriate for
the question that representative
spillsbury asked because it gives us a
flavor of the state
and so i was thinking about the various
businesses you have the business that
took ppe dollars and regardless of how
they invested it or
used it they folded and declared
bankruptcy they had no
business profits tax to speak of
you then have a company that changed
their way
received the ppe monies
uh changed their model perhaps and
perhaps
broke even or had minimal profit and
therefore
not necessarily impacted with the
business profits tax and then you have
the other group that um representative
spillsbury talked about and
i'm trying to just to get a handle in
you on your in your experiences and in
your practices
there's another group that you know made
really
um a significant profit out of the covet
you know whether they were
they changed their business model they
were putting up plexiglas or whatever
that might be
but actually do have had a significant
profit and did take ppp
dollars do you have a sense and i'm just
trying to get a sense of
um percentages in your practices how
would those three groups break down
is the group that made a significant
profit
and impacted with the bpp
um attacks uh is that a large number or
just a sense i know you don't have an
exact number but where do you think
those three buckets lie
um yeah i guess that would be really
hard
i would just be guessing um
so i yeah i don't know
yeah i haven't done any sort of review
of that nature
are you impressed with a significant
number of uh businesses that have
changed their model and have had a
significant uh
increase in the profit margin of the
businesses as a result of kobe
i can't say that i can again i haven't
looked at that particular
ratio to determine if profit margins are
up for
and and if and if so what what
percentage of my clients that represents
i mean there's there are some absolutely
thank you
representative romney thank you mr chair
um one thing that came up in our
hearings was
a discussion of the main street program
which took some of the 1.8 billion that
the state got and
used it for a similar state driven
program
uh i'm just curious and my our
understanding is that
uh there's uh this per
this is totally different and that that
there'd be no forgiveness of
of uh of the revenue uh or the the
of the uh of the loan i don't even know
i think it was created as a loan program
i'm not even sure
but have any of your clients mention the
main street program to you
or whether they want to see
some kind of a similar thing done with
those revenues it's not being taxable
well i mean in terms of of businesses
that receive them
i'm sure any business owner would be
happy not to have to pay tax on them
um and you know in getting back slight
to the kind of the original question
when this all started is in terms of the
extensions and things
my firm at least has for for any client
unless there's a clear
indication that they're going to have to
pay the main street relief funds
those funds were included in 2020
even though it was presumed
even though there may be a small chance
they get to have to pay it back and so
that income is included in the 2020
estimates for the extensions
but i'm i can only imagine that
businesses would
be happy to see that the main street
funds are included with the non-taxation
of ppp funds if that happens
all right thank you
any further questions from the committee
members
i've seen and both
kevin and kyle and teresa thank you
very much for coming in and
uh helping us understand this situation
we
still have a ways to go and and good
luck to you representative
and to all of you thank you for
including us representative
right before you go
i gotta and i thank every member
got a uh email from a
cpa organization
and it looks like they're taking a stand
you know
of many cpa organizations that are
taking a stand
one way or the other relative to senate
bill 3.
um i'm i'm not aware i'm
i'm not aware i i don't know yeah no no
no no do you have the do you have the
specific organization name
yeah i've got it uh resident major if
you want
i had uh that's uh
mason rich okay
so there's specific firms not
necessarily the cpa society
yeah that's right this was mason rich
professional association
and it just came in this morning i guess
this morning i i read it once and i oh
my god
and i'm gonna have to read that slowly
again yeah it's it's tense
uh i was surprised i would have thought
that
most cpas would be neutral
but you know you don't know of many uh
cpas that are
out there but i don't i don't know how
many more of these letters we're going
to get from cpa
groups representative major
um i think robin abbott is own listening
to this
and she may be able to give some light
if maceman rich has contacted the
society about
a physician to my knowledge we haven't
heard from anyone
in the individual society asking for
position we've heard from a lot of
individual society excuse me uh
individual
firms asking what the outcome
is of senate bill 3 and it's been more
for clarification how to treat
um treat the the grant or loan
um in in the tax returns but
uh robin may be able to say if others
have contacted her
out of position but to my knowledge um
we've really been hearing mainly from
firms of have you all made a decision
okay i notice in the attendees
there's a nhs cpa is that a firm or an
organization
that would be robin abbott the executive
director of the new hampshire society of
cpas
would she be willing to join us
just promoted her thank you
uh robin i am here can you hear me
yes were you able to um listen to the
discussion
i did listen to the whole discussion and
thank you very much for having us on
today
um i missed the last maybe 10 seconds of
your comments but i
theresa summed it up very nicely as well
as carl and
kevin so i really want to thank them for
being present they are they are
stellar in what they do and which is why
they represent our tax committee
but to your point um i would say there
are no specific firms that have reached
out to us with the position
however many have shown quite
a great deal of interest on which they
would this was going so that they could
advise their clients
because their clients have been very
stressed about this situation in
particular
the one organization i would say that
does take a stand that you may know of
is a national organization called the
american institute
of certified public accountants that's
the aicpa
so many of you have probably heard of
them before
they tend to take a more national
legislative stance
and oftentimes will trickle down their
guidance to us
whether or not we use that is really up
to the society
and and our board and our members and
and carl said it perfectly
um as did kevin as we are neutral on
bills but what we try to do is educate
our members
and educate the legislators as far as
you know what both sides are or
are doing so i hope that answers your
question
uh yes it does thank you does the
committee
have any further questions to ask of
this distinguished
group of people representative major
representative tudor here
did i hear um you talk about a stroll
straw poll in the beginning of this that
i missed that or
were you going to tell us about a straw
be i'd be happy to tell you it was
really just kind of a soft pull to some
of my more active members as far as what
their sentiment was on
sb3 and many who have had interest in
this from the beginning
um and i would say you know carl summed
it up perfectly
most cpas are really
participating in extensions with their
clients or
if they aren't they are paying a portion
of of what they expect as the ppp
with with a bit of um you know
uncomfortableness i i
would say what i hear mostly is that
most of our members
and again we do not take a stand but
most of our members are in support of
sb3 we're one of the only states that is
sort of taxing this money so
kind of has an icky feel to it when when
and i understand our tax structure is
very different from other states
around the country including in new
england but what we've sort of heard is
that
people are feeling sort of not so great
about being taxed
on sort of this found money um but again
understanding our tax structure is
different um
you know we're doing what we have to do
but i will say this
and and to credit carl and kevin for
being here today
when there was that irx extension on the
17th and they had the deadline on the
15th
this has probably been one of the worst
years
by far for members that they have ever
experienced i mean i'm getting calls on
a
routine basis of yep that's it i'm done
i'm hanging up my for sale sign
i'm good i'm not doing this anymore it's
been really challenging
so if there's any way that you can make
the practitioners and their
clients lives a little bit clearer a
little easier
that would go a long way right and
clear and easier doesn't mean you're
taking a stand
exactly does not
all right any uh further questions
saying thank you very much for pairing
with us today you're welcome thank you
thank you and so committee member
why don't we just take a quick couple
minute break
and then we'll go to the next issue
okay
so
um
this is not back yet
do you need help figuring out the
the numbers for josh
representative major representative over
here
uh yes rumor has it that
sb3 is going to be put into the budget
by the senate rumor has it
the senate does what wants to do
wow all right uh chris
yes rooster major i'm here okay good
uh i think we can get started
and but having chris do
we have on our revenues
we have flow revenues that
money is taken from it such as
going to dhhs l chip
affordable housing and likewise
and chris is going to talk about these
you get committee members especially
those that have
come on the last few years uh
a history of how this happened and what
it does
so you're all set chris all right thank
you for major
um so the reason that i'm here today to
talk about this if if some of you were
on the call i think two
meetings ago and i brought up the liquor
commission there was a
potential for a transfer of liquor funds
over to
department of health and human services
for the new hampshire granite advantage
program
um and and we didn't know the amount we
still don't know the amount
and then the members of the committee
were asking you know what other programs
do we see money come in on a cash basis
that then is moved to
a restricted or a certain purpose
instead of going into the unrestricted
general fund and i named four that you
know in addition to that i named three
others that i was aware of
um as a follow-up repsome spillsbury
reached out to me to get a little bit
more information
um you know kind of why this occurred
and some of the history and and i had
done some work for him which he then
asked
reps a major just suggesting that maybe
i should talk to the committee
in total and kind of go over some of
these funds and how they occurred and
and where we are today with them so that
that's what i'm going to do at a kind of
a high level i'm going to share my
screen
and it's just going to be it's a
narrative of the different programs
basically law
or chapter law but i'll talk through
kind of how we got to that point
oh well i i can't share my screen
it's disabled right now but that's i'm
going to start with the l chip program
jenny jenae i just changed those
settings chris sorry about that
oh that's okay thank you jen
so you should see l-chip and some yellow
highlights so
so the l-chip program is the land and
community heritage investment program
it's a
program that matches local or non-profit
funds to conserve property buildings
throughout the state it's a competitive
program
it's something that you know started
back in the early 2000s and
for from 2002 to 2008
the legislature would put appropriations
in the budget
to fund l-chip and what would typically
occur is there'd be an appropriation for
a certain
amount through the budget process it
would be reduced or removed in
total so the program didn't have the
seed
money to do what it was charged to do
sometimes there was other efforts to add
money in separate bills and those
wouldn't
survive so there was lots of discussion
in the legislative body and
and interested groups to try to come up
with a dedicated funding mechanism for
the l-chip program
and what was decided is that a surcharge
on certain
um documents that the register of deed
register of deeds processes and
in this sheet before you can see
um roman 2 the highlighted part an
additional charge of 25
shall be assessed so that was the amount
that was agreed up to
in 2008 session
to fund the l-chip program and then what
occurred with that is they basically
said
register of deed you shall collect this
and remit it back to the state of new
hampshire basically
using the same mechanism that the rep
money comes to the state of new
hampshire
and it would go to the dra who would
then peel off or
or account for the rep the surcharge
related to the lchip program
and then that would be used to pay the
lchip program
through treasury if you were to look at
the operating budget you will find
in the treasury's operating budget
there's a an accounting unit
that is for l-chip so the treasury
actually cuts a check to l-chip at the
start of each um fiscal year
there's an estimated budget on what they
think they might gain in revenue
and if they don't gain that then they
don't get all the the appropriation
if they get more than what they've
estimated they're able to come through
fiscal
through treasury to accept the
additional revenue which they've done
the last few years
so so it is money that comes in and
on a monthly basis there's an adjustment
made to
remove it from the cash and put it where
it belongs with treasury to go to l-chip
right now they're estimating about five
million dollars a year that that is
removed as a result of the surcharge so
it's not the ret
tax that that is doing this it's it's a
separate surcharge
but it just comes in in the door kind of
on the back of the ret tax as it's
because back when they put this together
there was a lot of discussion about
creating more work at the local level
in terms of collecting and remitting
revenue back to the state so that's the
l chip i mean if anybody has any
questions
any questions i see representative
romney
yes uh thanks chris um so when we do our
revenue estimates
we're not including that 25 dollars no
no um usually that's kind of it's backed
out so that when you get to the end of
the year
you know there's throughout the every
month that's backed out of the
the uh cash number right so at the end
of the year there's an adjustment made
you've heard about all these adjustments
that occur at the end of the year
so when you get your total at the end
you know that the
five million you know it's been three to
five million a year
um is is not included in your base
number
okay so and i guess one other oh sorry
go ahead
okay i'm just wondering does that get
budgeted somewhere that five million or
is that just
money that comes into that fund so
that's budgeted in the treasury's uh
operating budget i get it okay so it's
been in there for a number of years
um and it continues to be there
for i think for a number of reasons i
think one of them is so that um
people who are interested in what's
going on with the lg program can
actually see there's an appropriation
that goes to that
to that program um one thing that did
occur
when when they this surcharge was put in
place the first few
um budget cycles the lchip program still
didn't get 100
of the revenue generated the legislature
would put language in
house bill 2 or or a version of the
trailer bill to redirect um
some of that revenue back to the general
fund these were years when
we were going through the great
recession or coming out of the great
recession
so you may have heard of you know if
you've been around at all you've heard
the term
uh rating dedicated funds you know rate
on the fund
and and so that was what's occurring and
there was efforts by
the supporters of the l-chip program and
other dedicated funds to
ask the legislature to stop doing that
so that since about 2017 i think
there's been no um adjustment that
everything has gone to the lchip program
and when we get the periodic reports
from the department of
data services it'll tell us like
a recent one says um l chip
approximately five hundred thousand
dollars which would be
which will come out of re tt on the 16th
of the month
yep yeah so
so there's an accounting for it but
depending on when you're looking at a
report it still may be in the cache
so that so it gets a little confusing
but it is adjusted out
and again when you're doing your
estimates in the committee
that's been accounted for
so the next is the the school building
aid debt service
that comes out of the meals and rooms
tax so again similar to
tourette there's a note typically on
some of the um reports that you get that
says
by the certain day of the month the the
amount going to the building a debt
service will be
um will be removed from from the the
numbers
so what occurred here is back in 2008
well 2009 10 and 11 so so those
fiscal years but starting in 2008
session year
there was concerns on with the recession
just getting
started a concern on meeting the promise
to the communities that had borrowed
money to build school buildings and the
state
school building aid program where they
match a percentage i think it's up to
like 20
of of the cost of of the debt service
for these
buildings at that time um you know
building aid it was a significant amount
of the budget it was about 40 million
dollars a year
and decisions had to be made on how do
we fund some of these things we don't
have the revenue to support it
so back in 2009 during um this was
what i'm showing you is the language
that's contained in chapter 144 laws of
2009 that was house bill 2 at the time
you're going to see that a number of
things occurred with the meals and rooms
tax at that time
it went from 8 to 9 so that's the first
part of this
um you're going to see there was a
section put in that said
you're going to take the amount
necessary so they get the yellow bold
here
to pay the interest on the bonds and
notes that were authorized
and the 198 colon 15a relates to the
school building aid
debt as well as the amount of 3.15
percent
that would go to the former dread travel
and tourism
that number came up earlier this with
this committee
about a month ago six weeks ago there
was some question about this number
being suspended in the budget
and that is correct so instead of
the budget reflecting 3.15 percent of
the meals and rooms collected it's it's
something slightly less than that
there's still over 17 million dollars
over the biennium going to travel and
tourism but
the governor and the house proposal is
slightly different than what 3.15 would
equal
and as i said the the school building
aid during that period
in 2009 it was going to be a 40 million
appropriation
and then in 10 and 11 it was just under
45 million and then 46.2 million
so you're paying on this debt service
out to 2030
so until that point unless something
changes you'll see
an amount um taken off every month
to pay this uh bond debt service related
to the bonds for school building aid
the amount is the amount is going down
now so the the high point or the most
that was ever paid in a particular year
was about 14 million
it's down to about 8 million now a year
and it'll continue to trickle down as we
get closer to the end
again it was it was a decision made at a
time when revenues were
um lower than anticipated
um there was no projection to go forward
but the state wanted to to continue to
meet that
obligation or promise it had made to the
schools
and the communities related to the
school building aid
so that's all i really had to say on
that and i can move to the next thing
unless
there's a question it doesn't seem to be
any questions go ahead
all right i just raised my hand norm
[Music]
i just happened to notice on the first
page of that last
two slides that campsites were to be
taxed and that that didn't last very
long now did it
no no that's why i didn't bring it up
i couldn't resist i know that was ripped
very quickly and i guess i should say
the
part of the reason i show you that that
there was an increase in the meals in
rooms tax rate
that was part of the debate for
justifying that it was okay
to at least for the the uh biennium they
were budgeting for the 10 and 11
biennium
that increase would have allowed for
enough money to cover the debt service
associated with the school bonding aid
skill school building a bonding debt
service so
that was the reason i showed it there it
wasn't to create any other
discussion
the next and the more recent um
one that is that you guys are hearing
about is the liquor fund transfer
related to the new hampshire grant
granite advantage
so as many um as many people know back
in 2014
the um
there was changes to medicaid and health
insurance through
through uh um
the uh yeah why why is it slipping me
that basically president obama's changed
to health care
and one of the changes was to allow for
an expansion to medicaid
and there was a lot of discussion a lot
of concern in the state
as in many states about this expansion
and the costs associated with it
when it was first proposed the federal
government
was paying 100 of that expanded
expansion cost or the medicaid
cost associated with that and then over
the years
it was going to come down from 100
percent to where we are today
at 90 percent um so there was concerns
that
and it was kind of likened to the idea
of uh
special ed funding that the feds had
always promised it would be provided to
states and and
um there was feelings that they've never
fully lived up to that promise
that they would do the same thing with
the federal dollars associated with the
medicaid expansion so the legislature
passed bills to get it started and then
again in 2018
because of some changes with the funding
mix
re-authorize it as the new hampshire
granite advantage healthcare
program and then created a trust fund
and one of the things in the trust fund
that was negotiated at the time and has
been a focus
is that no state general fund shall be
deposited into the fund
so the medicaid expansion program should
continue forward without any general
funds that was very important and
something that's remained in statute
since then
but as we've gotten increased in the
numbers of people participating in the
program
along with the funding
mix being more the state providing a
greater share
there was some concerns that
there's not enough money coming in
through the health insurance premium
or any other way that is covering the
full
cost between the 90 percent the federal
government pays for in the 10 percent
that the state would be responsible for
so in the in the law there's a section
it's uh
romans six and you're going to see the
highlighted piece if you were to remove
the highlighted piece that was that's
what was there
up until 2019. so basically read the
commission accords with the most current
available information
shall be responsible for determining
quarterly commencing no later than
december 31 2018
whether there is sufficient funding in
the fund to cover projected program
costs for the non-federal share
for the next six month period if at any
time the commissioner
determines that a pr projected shortfall
exists
he or she will terminate the program in
accordance with the federally approved
terms
and conditions issued by cmc
so prior to the liquor commission aspect
being added that was the concern
and if that language wasn't in there
earlier this year
health and human services would have had
to abide if
there had been no change would have had
to abide by this language and start to
terminate
or close down the medicaid expanded
program because of
a lack of funding so one way to
address this was to use the liquor
commission fund
and the suggestion is it's not
at this point it's not general funds so
you've you've still abided by the
uh no use of general funds um
but because of the uncertainty and
knowing what kind of shortfall you're
going to have in the out years
they've allowed for an open
appropriation and for the amount
necessary to be transferred from the
liquor commission fund
and then there's a statement that um you
know if there's then if there's no
if there's insufficient funds from the
liquor fund
then they shall at that point start the
process to close or
re eliminate the program
so that's that's how that occurred and
that's the reason it's occurred is that
the
the legislature a couple years ago was
looking for a
a mechanism that could fund the program
if there was a shortfall
without assigning general funds to it
and then the last one and probably the
most recent one
that you've seen is the affordable
housing affordable housing is not a new
issue in the state of new hampshire it's
been discussed uh
you know for over 10 years now in
various venues
if you were to do a simple search in in
the
bill search function in on the website
um you're going to see bills going back
you know like i said
10 years or more for study committees
commissions
bills that would have provided capital
appropriations to
do affordable housing incentives for
your municipalities and
and local governments to set up
affordable housing funds
and in the last few years you've heard a
lot of discussion about
workforce and the inability for the
workforce to find housing
which is creating some challenges for
businesses that want to grow
or expand or move into the area so this
last
budget session it was felt that you know
this is probably the right time to
dedicate or restrict five million
dollars a year that comes in through the
real estate um
um transfer tax to to
go into the affordable housing fund
and and then the housing finance
authority is responsible for that fund
and they would um be the group um making
it available to the communities and the
places and businesses that that would be
eligible for it
so you saw that hit the first time back
in september
of this uh f20 september 20
and uh it caused a lot of questions at
that time because as you saw
a reduction of a comment about a
reduction of 5 million dollars
for the the housing finance authority
for the affordable housing
in the revenue focus that came out after
that month
so i think you know the reason i'm
talking about this is just to provide
you a little bit of a
history that on why some of these
actions occurred it's
many times it's not as a result of oh
today i think it's a good idea that i
take money and restrict it from this
fund for a purpose that is fairly newly
discussed you most of these have
had discussions for a number of
legislative sessions
and there's been a number of different
efforts to find a way to
have a steady revenue stream for them
so so those are the four that you know
stuck out and that we you know i
kind of talked about at a high level the
other day and
this is just a little bit lower but
still at a high level
so that's all i have well thank you
chris
and with this mechanism if you continue
uh dedicating
these revenue streams to specific
items then there'd be a lot less general
funds that can be utilized to support
the rest of the
budget kind of short search
short circuits so they regular budget
process i i think reps have all me
jumped off the call for she had a
conflict with another meeting but if i
think she was on the call
she would probably um i'm going to
suggest that she would make a comment
about the whole dedicated
fund process where that you know that's
in some ways this is a is like that you
know it's it's restricting a certain
revenue
or a piece of a certain revenue for a
purpose the dedicated funds are truly
that where the revenue doesn't come into
the
um the collections of the general fund
or the highway fund or
that we see on in the revenue focus but
they're they go directly to those funds
the four that i just shared with you are
slightly different in that they do kind
of pass through
the the collection of the revenue that
that you see in the revenue focus but
and then they're deposited to a
a particular place i think
representatives hand up reps of major
props yeah i just want to ask
chris if you can send us this uh slide
pack yep
yep i'll i'll do that
all right well thank you very much chris
we all appreciate it
you're welcome and uh
janine thank you
the i've asked the dr80 president
if any update
on
the revenues
lost due to senate bill 3 and they
emailed you their latest estimate but
if they could bring in carolyn and
melissa
mr chair uh representative gomarlo cut
out so i've just promoted
carolyn melissa and devin oh thank you
good morning representatives good
morning
so carolyn could you give us an update
of where you are
on senate bill 3
and its effect on revenues yeah so
um what you saw this morning was our
analysis
of the um or
the fiscal impact assuming that all
ppp loans were issued
by the end of the month um that is a
fiscal impact of just under 100 million
dollars
and i saw a news article come across my
screen this morning that i didn't have
an opportunity to open
up that said that as of today they have
exhausted
the full appropriation for ppp so i
think that is a good
final um impact for you folks to use
i saw the same thing this morning
um right now uh you know where
where do we go from here i think the
department
is trying to look at some possible
methodologies
for helping you understand the
fiscal year impact of
our analysis you know we we've presented
it as a total but not
broken it up by fiscal year
but certainly we would expect it to
happen across
many fiscal years um representative
ames had forwarded the california
analysis and we're actually trying to do
some digging to see if we can speak with
someone
from california to see how they broke
their analysis up by fiscal year
for pp
for their ppp bill
yeah and the california on their
analysis they
they said it's gonna cost them six point
two billion dollars uh by forgiving the
loan
but i have no idea what their total
revenue is on
corporate taxes agreed and i also noted
when i
pulled up that bill it was a bit more
comprehensive than ours
it also included the impact
for certain federal treatment of
eidl loans which is not contained
without
within our sp3 so we'll have to
carefully sort of
uh evaluate whether the california
methodology
works for our bill um but we are looking
into that
excuse me
am i may represent major reps in ames
yeah uh that's great i'm glad you're
looking at that um
the other another difference for
california is that they've excluded
publicly traded companies and i don't
know what that
the dimensions of that would be but i
don't think we could do that in new
hampshire
even if we wanted to and then there's a
000 rule that they've got in there
so firms that have
who's i can't remember how it works but
there's a 25
000 um bar
in terms of revenues
maybe you can explain it i can't quite
put it together i think it's the 25
decline 2020 over 19.
thank you
and i think the only other thing that i
would add is i think
the testimony that you heard
from the cpas today was very helpful
um i think that we often don't have the
you know the very granular taxpayer
perspective on these things because
we're not return preparers
um so i think it's definitely helpful to
understand what they're seeing
in the field to know that really there's
a spectrum
of treatments that taxpayers have
adopted
and certainly we are seeing
currently and melissa can jump in with
the stats if she wants to
but we are seeing very high levels of
um extensions this year and
i think that means that we're going to
have
really limited information about what
taxpayers have done
on their 2020 returns until such time as
those
extended returns are in fact filed
um what we have now for data is just
so limited that it's not particularly
useful
if i may comment uh that
go ahead yeah um
yeah so the extensions are um
correct me if i'm wrong but the amount
of money
um paid with uh for extensions
is is unprecedented in size
and um and yet it's a black hole for you
you don't
all you have is a number is that correct
that's exactly right melissa do you have
the exact stats
sure melissa allen senior financial
analyst for the department
um yeah everything you're saying
representative ames is completely
accurate
so extensions this month were 131.5
million
that is we have a 10-year trend on the
estimate analysis and voucher analysis
that we send out to you and that is by
far the highest we have ever seen
it's 195 percent above fiscal year 20
however i caution you to compare it to
fiscal year 20 because we do know that
the federal due date and
state new hampshire due date in fiscal
year 20 was extended to june
um for new hampshire and july for
federal but if you do
um compare that to fiscal year 19
it's about 50 or 51 million above
or 63 above 2019
so a very significant um
increase in dollars and counts for sure
for
extensions representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman uh
i i thought that the the question that
representative ames
asked yesterday during our discussion
about timing
um posed potential conundrums that we
hadn't thought about and i certainly
wasn't in a position to uh uh to clarify
so both of the accountants who
spoke to us this morning
alluded to that same concern
when they were talking about the
relative merits
of amending
sb3 versus
just not passing it and
it it seemed to me when they were saying
that
that the discrepancies in timing
actually highlight
a fundamental flaw in
the uh intent of sb3 and that is
if it's already true
that qualifying for loan forgiveness
requires uh deploying
the funds for qualified uh expenses
they've already been offset
uh what we're doing here if we also
allow
the deductions to be taken is we're
de-linking
uh the expenses from the source of funds
and this de-linking this this allowing
expenses that were already used that
were already paid for with one set of
funds
to be deducted against another set of
revenue
is exacerbating the timing problem
was there i yeah i agree and um i
was there a question or were you just
asking if i agreed with that
uh i suppose i'm asking if you agree
but i i i guess the point is that if the
amendment
the purpose of the amendment to sb3 is
in effect to neutralize the impact of
sb3
is it probably not correct that the
accountant's observation
is it might be better to just not pass
sb3
because that would be the less
complicated route
yes i agree that um
that it would certainly
be a complication to taxpayers relative
to the timing of the disallowed expenses
um and i think that exists
potentially as well with
sb3 as proposed in both scenarios i
think what you're looking at
is the possibility of a large number
of amended 2020 returns
regardless of what form senate bill 3
ultimately takes but as
you can certainly imagine
an amended return that results in a
reduced
tax liability feels a bit different to a
taxpayer
than an amended return that results in
an increased
liability so i think
for planning purposes one is probably
more palatable to a taxpayer than the
other
thank you good observation
rep senator brandon that leads us to the
question of
the same conversation here of uh whether
we amend our
uh if we amend
is it is it the same as
just killing the bill in terms of
revenue impact
so if you amend
the the bill concurrent with uh
representative spillsbury's draft
amendment i think what you would see is
a
very drastic reduction in the fiscal
impact
but there would be
still a small fiscal impact i believe
that the requirement to qualify for
forgiveness was not that 100 percent
be spent on qualified expenses i believe
it was
80 be spent on qualified expenses
and so there would still be potentially
a 20
or less amount
of what we've currently calculated that
would be a fiscal impact but it would
certainly be
significantly decreased i follow up
misters so what i to take away from what
they were saying uh that the accountants
related to bet
i guess would be a bit different then
with the amendment or or killing the
bill
or amending it there may be some
interaction with the bet that may be a
little different is what i kind of took
away from
what they were saying
yeah i think the direct bet impact
is the same regardless of
how sp3 makes it out
of committee if it does um the bet
direct impact is um
is the same i believe what uh carl and
kevin were saying
was that for many taxpayers
they have so much bet credit that
um sb3 doesn't really impact
their ultimate tax liability
um and that is actually baked into
our our analysis that you have currently
we
we account for those taxpayers that
will not have a bet or will not have a
bpt
liability due to their bet credit um
regardless of what we do okay thank you
can i interject one other thing
uh yes so may 11th is coming upon us
the six days away uh a general question
anybody is anybody heard
including dra of of the treasury
federal treasury coming up with guidance
on the 1.9 trillion dollars
that does have a bearing on our
discussions i think
and i i i haven't heard any anything has
anybody heard anything
i've been looking i haven't seen
anything right we're all waiting for the
guidance
and it's six days away we're not going
to
exact senate bill 3 on the 11th if we
don't have
more information such as this guidance
right
i'm just just reminding everybody that
that's still hanging out there
thank you any further questions asked
of the dra if not
i want to remind the committee that
before we get to
house bill 565
next week we're going to have an exact
session on tuesday
hopefully we'll exact six of the seven
bills
the one we won't be exacting the senate
bill 3
unless we get additional information
and then on wednesday the 12th
we're going to continue with revenues
and hopefully
we can have somebody come in and i'm
hoping that we have
guidance on the latest stimulus
that would help us
the next thing we want to discuss is
representative romney
has been working with the senate
relative to
house bill 565 which we had passed
and it also appears
in an anonymous bill over there so
represent
romney would you explain that yeah so i
touched on it briefly yesterday but i
i since then i did have a conversation
with senator d'alessandro
and with representative hill who chairs
the
legislative administration committee
which is where this
is senate bill 100 which is an omnibus
bill
and section four relates to a uh
committee to study charitable gaming
so our uh representative
and i chatted with representative ames
uh yesterday morning about this as well
uh but now i got a little more detail so
house bill 565 passed out of our
committee which was our version of
of the uh a study committee uh chair
study channel gaming committee
uh passed unanimous out of us that
passed on the floor in consent
whenever the senate the senate passed it
uh but then put it on the table
it's still unclear why they put it on
the table but i could think of some
scenarios why they put it on the table
now in our bill we just said three
members of the house
and two members of the uh picked by the
speaker
and two members of the senate appointed
by the senate president
in the hou and the senate version
they they say two members of the senate
one that comes from finance and one that
comes from ways and means
and then they say in their version they
say three members of the house
one from ways and means one from finance
and then
the other is either or or
other committee appointed by the the uh
house speaker so
what i suggested to senator d'alessandro
this morning is that you know we have no
problem with the senate picking who they
want to be on their
on the committee um but
we may want to change what
the makeup on our side is and uh
i said uh i i think
i think it's better that that the
members come all from ways and means
because
on the house side because we're the most
familiar with this
and then per our conversation yesterday
representative um
how many i suggested well can we make it
at least one from the minority party
which would probably happen on its own
uh usually these they usually if it's
three members it'll be two from the
majority party one from the minority
party most committees that i've been on
over the years that's the way it works
but we we could state it that way so
he had no problem senator alessandro
said yeah that's fine but why don't you
make it two and two
so that's another option um
this is not a partisan uh committee
uh at all we're just trying to study all
aspects of charitable gaming
uh so i'm fine with it either way
uh if we if we amend
senate bill uh 100
section part four where this resides
um to do to say either
uh two uh two members or three members
the
ways and means two from the majority
party one from the minority party
or four members of ways of means
to two members that come from the uh
minority party and two to come from
majority party
so uh i was just trying to get a feel
from the
committee of would anybody object if
uh either way on this
okay so and then i
i i uh so there's a chance these are
omnibus bills so when i talk to
uh to the uh representative hill
chairs legislative administration he
says that there's about
six or seven commissions or committees
that are there
he says there's probably going to be
only one or two that are going to
survive and they're going to amend out
some of these others so
ours being one that will survive and
then what i'm going to do i said well i
need to get you an amendment
he says no i don't do that i'm going to
be putting an amendment through
just give us the language that you want
for this which i'll i'll do
so uh but then he then he was a little
concerned about
and there's reason why we should pass
this and then also you know uh
support and then i asked senator del
sancho this morning
i said if we amend this and if
for whatever reason this omnibus bus
bill doesn't make it through the house
floor
uh that you'll be willing to amend the
house bill 565 in the same manner and he
said yeah absolutely so
we're good either way but but
uh representative hill said
you know there could be a reason why he
thought more conspiracy theory than i
did
there could be another reason why they
they tabled it
is because they may hang other bills
onto this one and make it a christmas
tree
and i see i like to laugh at rick
yes so uh
so he says yeah we'll make sure we pass
it so that
you know they can't make both of these
christmas trees so
uh because what happens if they do that
there's an odd
there's it could be that we just get so
frustrated with the senate
that they hung all these other things
that we just veto the whole you know we
we vote no on the floor to the amended
566 565 so
that's some of the high intrigue here
does anybody have a problem with what
pat has has said i i don't i
uh i guess i wonder um
i do have a a favorite between four
members from the house and two members
from the house
not really i'd be honest with you i i
think it'd probably be better
to have the four um that's what i'm
thinking too
about who's gonna show up from the
senate a little more participation on
our side
yeah i agree again it's not a partisan
thing to me it's
it's uh i don't think it is i i think we
need to have more representation there
um to keep the quorum or whatever to
do yeah yeah i'm gonna have to leave
right at noon so
i'm upset thank you all right i got what
i need to know are we all set
okay thank you for your participation
today
and uh i plan on having a republican
caucus at 10 o'clock on monday morning
and i'll talk to susan and she'll
be having one too that's the primary to
get us ready for the execution
of these senate bills on tuesday next
week
yeah and for democrats i'll be sending
out uh susan and i will be sending out a
uh a zoom notice for friday midday i
don't have the exact time
in my head but it's the same time it's
been
as has been stated 11 30 i think
what is it 11 30 yeah
yes um i have a rockingham uh
subcommittee meeting at 10 do you think
all right 11 i'm sorry do you think
we'll be uh
we'll be done in an hour
i i really don't know but
uh that's that's okay talk to me
separately and we'll work something out
okay
i i have to leave thank you everybody
okay bye-bye thank you